I know know which is how you say it
again
I know nothing about German I think the
German language has some like nuances to
it and has a nice flow to it the only
thing that I remember is blue tur often
I think it means funny monkey Ashe
comfort if it were like French it would
be our scrum pay our scrum our scrum feh
a dresser or some piece of furniture
I'm guessing it's pain in the ass you
were being such an ash grump that right
now I'm sure our SH o'clock ash luck our
slok that's gotta be [ __ ] everyone's
got an arch block pop suck Bob Sapp Bob
sux bob [ __ ] means boobs
condom face sounds like ball sac to me
oh so I'm a sad sack well you haven't
dated me Hannah bum did nothing 400 baba
Hannah bambbles honey bumper yeah that's
a fun word on a bumble you eat human
flesh and a hand mobile home you can't
even be lazy saint alert penis cook
Tina's cough penis hope
Tina's calm I'm guessing that's like the
German [ __ ] block you're a penis call
sounds like a disease penis [ __ ]
this what I love about the German
language is literally what it says
boycotted bolder more slow Darrell its
Voldemort's evil cousin what trouble boy
dropping so I want this to mean Voltron
ugly [ __ ] Germans a great language to
Kherson know I can't do the accent
without making fun of people unactivated